foreign
this morning on the dish a visit to the
Breakthrough London restaurant to tale
it's run by quasi brinyamensa who makes
use of his family's rich past cooking up
dishes that may be the African cuisine
of the future MTS tayab got a taste
it's considered one of the most exciting
and Innovative kitchens in London
bringing the flavors of Africa to some
of the world's most Discerning diners
Aqua zebra Mensa is the brains behind
tatale which is named after a Ghanaian
plantain pancake I wanted it to be
aligned with
um plantain plantain yeah absolutely you
know whether it's back home whether it's
in the states whether it's in South
America you know whether it's you know
black people that live in Iran like
plantain is in everyone's Cuisine and
that's what tatale is about hi Mom
you're on camera
taking the food his Ghanaian mother
would cook for him as a child and
broadening it to include Global African
influences
you're from South London you're a
Londoner but your family's food
tradition is so Ghanaian my parents were
very very Stern about the fact that we
were gone in
so
as an example we weren't allowed to
speak English in the home wow I think
it's probably as I got older
that I probably considered
um The Duality to my identity a duality
that led brenya Mensa to a career in
food in 2015 he noticed the surge in
popularity of gourmet burgers across
London and started his first pop-up in
his University Town of Sheffield which
grew to feeding music lovers at the
Glastonbury Festival what'd you call it
it was called the juicy kitchen the
juicy kitchen yeah inspired by Notorious
B.I.G okay who was on our logo and it
was all a dream used to read Word Up
magazines that's the one thank you very
much so that's yeah that's where it came
from and I was always kind of like wary
one day I'm gonna get like a cease and
desist letter or something but you know
we weren't major so it never came but
Tata lake is Major winning rave reviews
for its painstakingly precise menu
That's nearly all vegan like the black
eyed bean hummus with red palm oil and
Duca inspired by a trip to Tel Aviv one
thing that stuck out to me you know
especially as I West African or has it
gone in is that black eyed beans are
used extensively on a lot of our dishes
ultimately that's how we got to this
hummus it's really amazing and it's also
really smooth as well I would think with
black eyed beans and maybe have a bit of
grit to it one of the tricks that I was
showing was you know using the residue
water from the beans to kind of like
Smooth it out another dish where
black-eyed beans are the star is
tatale's signature menu item so red red
is um again a very traditional Ghanaian
dish it is a um it's called red red
that's it yeah it's
um a black eyed bean stew
made with tomatoes onions ginger garlic
but most notably red palm oil Rena Mensa
has taken out the traditional fish
accompaniment and uses fermented locust
bean instead that dish to me is tied to
my mom's kitchen and tied to growing up
and you know my mom's kitchen was like
the CEO's office it's more than taste to
me that in fact this is time travel
because at any point at which I have it
you know I'm transported to be in the
kitchen with my mum so and if you do
want to transcend time she sat in her
own mum's kitchen eating the very same
ditch yeah absolutely and on and on and
on exactly yeah
frenia Mensa is a self-described African
futurist alongside his own radio show
[Music]
Houston science technology and art
informs everything he creates
one of the most Transcendent items on
his menu is decidedly non-vegan the
chichinga buttermilk chicken served as
chicken wings is dusted in the
pan-african seasoning usually served in
kebabs
I've had a lot of chicken wings in my
time
this is so flavorful so Punchy the
pepper is like there to remind you that
you know this is a serious Affair
look I'm not going to be shy I'm going
to eat this to them no please please I
wouldn't have you eat any other way and
if you picked up your Cutlery I would
have grabbed you totally's location is
also rooted in its food ethos nestled
inside the newly relocated Africa Center
a vital Hub of political and cultural
activity for London's African diaspora
dating back to the 1960s
a phrase that keeps coming up is sort of
pan-african what does that mean to you
to me pan-african means black and so
when I talk about it being a pan-african
concept I'm talking about it being a
black concept
um so for you pan-african isn't just
the 54 countries of the continent of
Africa it is black people everywhere
absolutely and you put that in your
dishes dishes which excite as much as
they Inspire everything you've served
here has been really approachable and
really flavorful is that what you want
people to to feel when they come in yeah
absolutely and if you are not so
familiar with this Cuisine or these type
of ingredients and come away having
enjoyed it fantastic come back and yeah
absolutely please do but if you are
familiar or you have some experience and
you try something and it it can write
some memory or takes you somewhere else
then I'd be thrilled
for CBS Saturday morning India's Tire
London
so MTS shipped over uh one of the
several drinks with an apple here not
alone
it's made with rum so lava taste um
and I I love when he he just keeps
talking about time travel right yeah and
like how that that's what food does for
him and cooking and bringing it back to
the kitchen of his mom right yeah well I
just for the record they're not black
eyed beans they're black eyed peas I'm
just saying he's stepping in I am
stepping ambo this drink though
refreshing it really is it's the elder
flower the elderflower lemon also and
apple delicious yeah thank you